this holiday season shopping habits for
american consumers is probably going to
look a lot different than normal
as companies continue to keep
stay-at-home measures in place
people are shopping for clothes they can
spend all day in comfortably
not just for themselves but also as
gifts for the holidays
we've really been talking about the home
centric lifestyle well before covet 19.
once the pandemic hit it really
accelerated some of the trends we were
already seeing
particularly in athleisure and the
lounge space
although fashion struggled especially
during
the early part of the pandemic certain
categories have gained a little bit more
attention
total apparel from march to september
declined to 27 but the decline in
activewear
in athleisure was more in the single
digits down 9
for full year 2019 the total apparel
market was 224 billion dollars in the us
and activewear was 27 of that with
uh close to 60 billion dollars now from
march to september
we're seeing that activewear is gaining
to make up almost a third of sales and
it's now
32 percent of sales and apparel
athleisure sales are expected to go
up but analysts say other apparel
categories are
not surprisingly way down so when most
of us
in the us started to begin our social
distancing and
quarantining we wanted to understand how
were we spending our time when we were
home and one of the things we went out
to americans to ask was
which of the following describes what
have you done since you stayed from home
during the coronavirus in the past week
over half said that they wore activewear
all day
and he also had about 47 percent that
said that they were
pajamas or loungewear all day so
it was interesting to see the shift into
that because that's where the dollar
started to go towards
meanwhile black friday apparel sales
were strong this year so this could mean
good things for clothing companies
looking into 2021.
if people do go back to the office next
year they might not want to sacrifice
the comfort of cozy clothes
so this could mean companies will have
to adjust to consumer demands
27 of people who said that they worked
outside of the home prior to covet 19
were working outside of the home as of
march 29th
as of september 20th that number then
goes up to 46
of people being back into their
workplace which is going to be
interesting to see
now how has their apparel purchasing
shifted
um and what's going to be important is
that it's going to be versatile and it's
going to be comfortable because we're
not giving that
up but the two don't have to be mutually
exclusive and there can be
more dressier options obviously that
incorporate
comfort into the elements of it